[Applause]
Thank You Adam I'm so happy to be back
here thirty and something changed years
ago I worked at the California
Historical Society when it was out on
Pacific and Laguna and it's always fun
to be back wherever they happen to be so
I'm going to spend a little time tonight
talking to you about the man I have
spent over twenty five years of my life
with and hopefully by the end of the
evening you will understand why so I was
hired as the very first historian
archivist for Levi Strauss & Co in 1989
and when I walked in the door I was not
too surprised that there weren't any
historical records because of this this
is a picture of the company headquarters
April 20th 1906 after the building had
survived the massive earthquake but not
the fire it's not unusual you go to work
for a company in San Francisco that was
founded before the earthquake you're not
going to have much but I didn't really
understand what kind of impact that was
going to have on my work so I'm the
first historian archivist ever ever
hired so it was really important for me
to get up and running and understand the
history right away so I started reading
published histories of the company
things newspaper articles interviews
with company managers going back 50 60
70 years and I heard some interesting
stories that tend to kind of contradict
themselves occasionally but the basic
story was that Levi Strauss arrived in
San Francisco in 1850 off a clipper ship
and he saw miners walking around San
Francisco with raggedy pants and there
or like ripping through their pockets
and he's decided to make a pair of pants
out of canvas then he either later dyed
them blue or got the fabric from France
it depended on who wrote the story and
then later he put some rivets in them
and then tada there were jeans all right
well the more I kept reading and the
more I kept reading the actual materials
that the few materials that had survived
I realized that these stories had been
completely made up and guess who made
them up the company yeah that bless
their little pointed heads they really
tried they really tried to tell their
early history but they didn't have
anything to
work with and these stories kind of
arose about the time of World War two
when there was a lot of competition in
the denim world and the company needed a
powerful origin story about its jeans
and they made some assumptions based on
what they had and we were left with 1850
clipper ship ripped pockets denim from
France so although I have to say my very
favorite story about the origin of the
company was the London Sunday Times
which said that the company had been
founded by Claude lévi-strauss the
French anthropologist my personal
favorite so it took my entire time
almost 25 years of the company to track
down the story because there were no
records and I'd really did have to
travel to find to find this story and in
between my regular duties that's what I
would do is ferret out information about
this man so what I found was actually a
person that was so much more interesting
than the mythology he was the sort of
cardboard cutout and even here in the
tower town San Francisco he was this
kind of cardboard cutout but what I
eventually found was a person more
interesting more complicated than
anybody I could have imagined so let's
start with his beginning he was born
lewb Straus lol out B Straus February 26
1829 in the Bavarian town of Boonton
Heim actually Boonton high Miz in the
Franconian region of Bavaria so if you
ever go there and you tell people that
you know their Franconian they will love
you and probably buy you a beer
so they really have proud to be part of
the Franconian part of bavaria his
father Hirsch was a peddler his
grandparents grandfathers were cattle
traders peddling of course was a
traditional Jewish occupation Levi's
mother was actually here Strauss a
second wife he had five older siblings
half siblings and then he and his sister
Fanny were the son and daughter of
hirtius second wife so he grew up going
to the tiny little synagogue and tiny
little Boonton Haim and going to school
but he and the entire family and every
Jewish citizen of Boonton Hine was
living under something called the udin a
dict with a law that had been passed in
1813 that was intended to make
citizens out of the various Jews but
really just took away so many so many
rights and one of the things that was
done to do this was every village after
the udin ADAC went into effect had to
have a list called amat racquel which
was the list of every citizen in every
town and it had very specific rules only
those who were listed on the mat raquel
could marry or change their residence
within the boundaries of the kingdom in
addition the right to marry was limited
to the eldest son in the family a
younger son could marry only if a
childless couple gave up a spot on the
mat raquel for him if he married a widow
who also was on the list or if he left
his village and married in another or if
a place on the list opened up basically
it was about the list and there was a
you were a younger son you couldn't
marry there were a lot of unsanctioned
unions and illegitimate births and a lot
of these very very small towns in
bavaria the other bigger problem that
the udin ADAC had was it did not allow
Jews to carry on their traditional
occupations peddling cattle trading two
of the biggest occupations for the
region unless you were sort of
grandfathered in and you were too old
and you already had that occupation you
had to take up farming or small crafts
it would be a shoemaker or soap maker or
whatever so the the oldest Straus boy
was Jakob he could marry he could do
whatever he wanted but he still couldn't
be a peddler like his dad not to mention
this for the three other boys in the
house they had no opportunities
whatsoever so in 1837 18 young people in
Boonton Heim just got up and left and
two of them were the two oldest Straus
children Jakob who went to London and
who Isla
the oldest sister went to New York three
years later the two other boys went to
America Jonathan who became Jonas and
Lippmann who became Louis they left in
1840 in 1841 went to New York and soon
became very prosperous and we're sending
letters back home about how good things
were in New York then in 1846 here
Strauss dies of tuberculosis and his
wife Rebecca has a big decision to make
she has her own to chill
and the younger youngest stepdaughter
and so she makes the important and
necessary decision to go to America now
if you wanted to leave Bavaria and go to
America you can just get up and leave
you had to apply to the Bavarian
government and tell them why you wanted
to leave and you had to make sure you
had to tell them why without insulting
the Bavarian government at the same time
and thanks to the record-keeping in the
State Archives in Bamberg we actually
have the statement that Levi Strauss
himself wrote to explain the reasons why
he was leaving along with his mother
it's really very poignant the favorable
news that I have received from my
stepbrothers in America has convinced me
to follow them even though I do not have
at this time a specific occupation but
my brothers will take care of that no
members of my family will stay behind I
will share the fate that has been
assigned to me with them in foreign
lands I just joined my mother in her
plea so it was you know I don't I don't
have a career here just like my brothers
you know there's no career here but I'm
going to go to America and I'll have
something to do this is very important
because if you left of area you had to
leave money behind so that if you struck
out in America or London and came back
home you were not a burden on the state
so sometimes between spring and autumn
1848 Rebecca
Strauss and her three children got on a
ship in Bremen and went off for New York
and you can read in the book about the
ghastly steerage passage that you had to
take to get to New York and then they
were very happy to finally land where's
my technology in New York City and they
moved into an area called Klein
Deutschland which is today basically the
Lower East Side of New York but it was
so many both Christian and Jewish people
of from Germany was called Klein
Deutschland little Germany so they move
in with Lewis and Jonah Strauss who were
urban peddlers they had store accounts
and they would they would get stuff
wholesale and they would have their own
store accounts and they'd walk around
New York and they were basically urban
peddlers
their business was called Jay Strauss
and brother Jay for Jonas the oldest
brother he got to name the business
after him so Levi jumps in and he starts
learning the business and he's learning
English and then the census taker comes
around in 1850 takes the names of
everybody in the Straus household and
then there's someone named Levi because
he changed his name for a number of
reasons the most important of which was
nobody in America can pronounce lube the
other reason is Levi is a name from the
Bible
it's very common it's everybody knows
that Christian and Jew so it seemed like
the appropriate name for him to take for
his basically his business name although
it's very likely of course they called
him a little bit home then the gold rush
happens and all these reports are coming
back all the the Jewish mob so many
Jewish merchants are coming out to San
Francisco and Auburn and all of those
little gold rush towns and they're
setting up retail stores and they're
writing their families back home saying
come out to California the opportunities
here are amazing and if you wanted to
come to California and go into business
you had two opportunities you could be
the wholesaler you could stay in San
Francisco bringing the goods from New
York and have your retail accounts up in
the gold rush country or you could have
your small retail stores up there it was
this amazing sort of umbilical cord
between New York calluses in San
Francisco in the gold country so
sometime in 1852 the Strauss family
decides to send Levi to California to
basically open up the west coast branch
of J Strauss brother & Co now there's
still so many questions about Levi that
will never be answered unless somebody
finds a diary or a letter in a trunk
somewhere here's one of my big questions
if you jump or was he pushed did he want
to go did he think it was a great idea
or did the family sit at the dinner
table and say guess what you're getting
on the boat but he had something very
important to do and that before he could
leave and on January 31st 1853 he became
an American citizen he had registered
for naturalization almost the minute he
got off the boat in 1848 and became a
citizen and five days later he was on a
steamer for the Isthmus of Panama
now there were many ways to get to San
Francisco the fastest was to cross the
Isthmus of Panama there was no less
dangerous but it was fast so what you
did was you took a steamer from New York
to the Caribbean side of the Isthmus and
then in 1853 you could only take a
railroad half way across because it
wasn't finished then you had to take a
boat on the childís River and they and
then depending on what time of year you
were there for him it was February you
stopped at go to Ghana and then you
rented a mule from Wills Fargo and you
rent rented mule and you went took the
view all the way down to Panama City on
the Pacific side got another Pacific
Coast Pacific Mail steamship company up
to San Francisco which is what Levi did
so he crossed the Isthmus he turned 24
years old 24 on the trip up I think he
had just passed Acapulco on his way to
San Francisco and he landed here on
March 14th 1853 so he's a very serious
young man and again
records are scarce but I am almost
positive that he arrived in California
with letters of introduction from
merchants in New York that he could take
up to the gold rush country to a store
and say the letter would say I'd like to
introduce you to mr. Levi Strauss he's
new in business please give him your
custom he had probably also arranged to
have a warehouse near the waterfront
where he could store the the dry goods
that his brothers had already put on a
clipper ship that was going around the
horn and it's very likely he slept in
that warehouse I found a lot of letters
and diaries and newspaper accounts of
young merchants sleeping in their
warehouses on a mattress and blanket
where the fleas don't let me sleep we
all know how flea-ridden San Francisco
was so one of the very first customers
that we know of that Levi found was the
store Hardy and Kennedy in Forest Hill
which is near Auburn and this is the
sort of collection of dry goods that his
brothers would send him pants shirts
boots children's clothing lace monty is
for ladies dry goods was basically
anything that wasn't hardware or food it
was sort of the the soft goods of
everyday living and this is what he was
bringing in and he cultivated all these
retail clients and he started this sort
of web beginning in California which
very kept on going
one of the things we know the least
about is about Levi Strauss is faith we
know he was Jewish we know that he
worshiped at Temple Emmanuel and that's
just about it
I would really like to know if some
Sabbath day if he was in the Pew next to
Emperor Norton you know one of those
days I really really wish I knew that
because he went there as well I know
that by the 1890s Levi was on the
advisory board of the Emmanuel
sisterhood for personal service which
was like the Women's Auxiliary of the
temple but that's about all we know
we don't know what his personal feelings
were about his faith but we'll find out
a little bit later one of the things
that he practiced very very assiduously
that does reflect very much his faith
when the Civil War came to California
Levi was by the way a abraham lincoln
republican he voted for Lincoln in 1860
in 1864 he gave a lot of he and the
company gave a lot of money to the
sanitary commission which were those
organizations that helped to create
better conditions in hospitals and
battlefield medical units to keep
soldiers healthy during the during the
Civil War he joined something called the
committee of 34 which kept their eyes
open looking for any reasonable
combinations or conspiracies against the
Union and the public peace and there was
a reason for that because there were a
lot of Southern sympathizers in
California and San Francisco it was a
very real threat Levi Strauss & Co as
well as many others prospered during the
Civil War because Eastern American Corp
ports were blockaded so California wheat
and wool and dry goods were able to get
to Great Britain and make a lot of money
during the Civil War so he did prosper
he did do well and in the 8th late their
mid to late 1850s his sister Fanny and
her husband David Stern and their
children moved from New York out to Cal
to San Francisco to live with Levi
so we've here for a loan for the first
three years that he lived here by 1867
the company was in this headquarters by
the way that picture we saw at the very
beginning of the you know building that
went down this is what it looked like
before the earthquake and fire I know it
was beautiful it was on battery between
Pine and California I believe the
beautiful beautiful
and they had started off at just 1416
battery street and by the time of the
earthquake it was 10 to 24 battery
street they had basically the entire
block so the company had been just
levi-strauss so by the time of by about
1863 it was Levi Strauss & Co the family
was here his sister Mary had passed away
and her husband was now out here as well
with his children so it was really
becoming a family business now it was
easy to make money in San Francisco but
it was also easy to lose it what Levi
regularly did was put gold called
treasure my favorite historical word
treasure on to Pacific Mail steamships
that went down to the city asmath were
carted across the isthmus put on another
steamer to go up to new york that goal
he sent that gold to his brothers to go
into the bank to buy more drugget well
he had the company had seventy six
thousand dollars in gold on the Central
America which is this boat which went
down in a hurricane off of South
Carolina in September of 1857 that's
about two million dollars of value today
now some people found that boat in the
1980s and in the early 90s one of them
called me and he said he found a trunk
with a pair of pants in it which you
know was not true but I'm like you know
seventy six thousand dollars that gold
belonged to us that didn't go very far
you know hey you know neener neener we
found it but it's very likely the
company did get an insurance payment
they were very good about making sure
that those a lot of those shipments were
insured Levi had a pretty good
Salesforce set up by the 1870s
here they are all none of them none than
wearing Levi's at least not that I can
tell because they weren't invented yet
but they were probably wearing denim
some of the ones in the back are working
the loading docks or in denim and what's
really interesting is that Levi had dry
goods customers in Mexico Canada and
Hawaii in the late 1860's and early
1870s he really early understood the
value of the Pacific Rim which I find
very fascinating so he thinks I'm going
to you know I'm going to be a wholesaler
for the rest of my life I'm prosper
you know my family is growing my sister
and her husband are having more kids the
business of doing great I'm a happy
capitalist and that's what he thought
you'd do for the rest of his life until
1872 when he got a letter from this guy
this guy is jacob davis who was born
jakob rufus in riga which is now Latvia
which at the time was Russia one of
those four places that gets bopped all
over the map throughout history but it
was Russia at the time he came to the
United States in 1854 worked in the East
he was trained as a tailor as a teenager
back in Latvia Russia he came to
California in late 1854 decided to try
the whole gold mining thing and it
didn't really work so he had changed his
name to Davis by this time so he was
kind of went all over the place and he
was saved by the mid-1860s he was up in
Canada he got married started to have a
family ran a brewery but every time he
sort of didn't make it very well he
would go back to tailoring in 1867 he
was in Virginia City which is you know
one of the hubs of the Comstock you know
mining regions and he described it as a
populated of 15,000 people of which
5,000 were miners about 5,000 of bummers
gamblers and prostitutes at about five
thousands of businessmen speculators and
capitalists which is why it was such a
fun town then in 1868 he moved to Reno
literally days after Reno had been
officially established it was on with
clustered built up and clustered around
the Central Pacific Railroad like a
local business has supported mining and
agriculture and he set up there as a
tailor tried running a brewery again he
actually had the Reno brewery for a
while then there was another silver
discovery in Ely in the east and so he
went out there you know did some
tailoring you know even tried to store
keeping for a while but he always came
back to Reno and he by this time was
making Kent covers horse blankets and
wagon covers Oh in tents as well as
wagon covers in tent so in December
December 1870 genu Airy 1871 a woman
walks into his tailoring shop and says
my husband needs a new pair of pants but
they've all fallen apart he literally
can't
go out in public so I'm here to ask you
to make a pair of pants for my husband
so he sends the wife back to her husband
with a string and says please measure
his waist so she comes back and she says
would you please do something to make
these pants not fall apart my husband
just goes through these pants like you
just can't believe so he was working
with a fabric called duck which comes
it's a kind of a lid in canvas it comes
to the the Dutch for canvas and it's a
pretty sturdy stuff but kind of an
off-white and then he had an over on the
table he had some horse blankets
and he used to reinforce the seams and
the stress points of horse blankets with
rivets and he looks up at this table any
thinks huh I wonder if I could put some
rivets in these pants if they would hold
together better so he did he put rivets
in the pocket corners the base of the
button fly held on the little strap in
the back that they had before belt loops
gives them to the woman he sees the guy
walking around town wearing his pants
and he hurt and the guy was really
really happy and then people start
hearing about these pants of Jacob
Davis's and they're coming into his into
his shop and asking to buy some more so
he realizes he's got a big sort of
money-making idea on his hands and he
was a frustrated inventor actually a
partly successful inventor he actually
had a patent for a type of closed press
already and he really he always thought
big and he wanted to mass manufacture
and mass-market these pants so a lot of
the fabric he had in his tailoring shop
he got from Levi Strauss & Co one of his
wife's cousins had come to the city and
went into the wholesale warehouse and
brought back some denim some duck some
thread whatever so he knew the name Levi
Strauss
he knew the reputation of Levi Strauss
so what did he do he has this
money-making idea he sends examples of
the pants down to Levi Wells Fargo
Express and with a letter that says here
is a big money-making idea let's go into
partner let's be partners and do this
together well you know that shows a lot
of trust you have to admit I mean what
what would have prevented Levi from
running off with the idea but of course
he knew Levi's reputation and he knew he
wouldn't do that he also knew that even
though Levi wasn't a manufacturer he was
a he
he thought big was a big idea guy and he
would probably think this was a big idea
and he literally did in the documents
that are in copy The Witcher in the
National Archives in Philadelphia
there's his handwritten pencil note note
a lawyer write to this guy sign him up
like now I mean literally days after he
wrote this letter in July July of 1872
so the patent was awarded on here's a
lovely rivet copper but and the patent
was awarded after three tries with the
Patent Office on May 20th 1873 for an
improvement in fastening pocket openings
which is really boring language for
basically the invention of the blue-jean
so this is gets pretty exciting right
off the bat there's a magazine published
out of San Francisco called Pacific
rural Press very influential with
ranchers farmers a lot of people who
make farm machinery whatever the kind of
people who would wear really tough
riveted pants and they had a little
article about the pants in one of their
issues and I want to read you a little
bit of it so they talked about you know
this this invention seems very simple
but it's really very effective and
effective and we are sure it's going to
become quite popular amongst our working
men nothing looks more slouchy in a
workman than to see his pockets ripped
open and hanging down and no other part
of the clothing is so apt to be torn and
ripped as the pockets besides its
slouchy appearance it is inconvenient
and often results in the person losing
things from his pocket all right
seriously I really don't think the guys
were worried that their pants look
slouchy you know but the point was there
would be no some more slouchy pockets
because they had rivets those pockets
had rivets in them so the first pants
were made of denim and this is actually
a picture of the oldest pair of jeans in
the archives I left two years ago as far
as I know there's still the oldest pair
of jeans in the archives they're from
about 1879 and they are a blue denim so
denim has one of those you know weird
histories that textile historians you
know get arm wrestling matches about
because nobody can really you know tell
knows the real story but basically denim
does was created first in France
probably in the 17th century and it was
a Serge fabric a type of weave from the
town of neem and so it says Dyneema and
so by the time English textile
manufacturers were making it they were
calling it the neem because even though
you have an English fabric if you give
it a zippy french name you know it's
really good marketing but eventually
they anglicized the word to denim and
then by the 18th century when American
textile mills started to make denim it
was always in English it was always in
English denim and it was always all
cotton even though in the very beginning
was actually a wool and silk blend
George Washington toured a Massachusetts
textile mill in 1789 and watched denim
being made so you know there and there's
still people who write and say that
Levi's got the denim from France for his
first jeans and they tended to tell
those stories in France was like no
first year the first jeans were made of
denim and the denim came from the
Amoskeag manufacturing company in
Manchester New Hampshire
it was the yeah it was it was the
biggest textile mill in the country they
made the very best denim they were so
huge they had their own foundry and when
they couldn't get enough cotton during
the Civil War they converted their
foundry and made guns they made fire
engines you know they were just
tremendous and they did make the very
best denim in the United States there
were no denim mills or textile mills in
California Levi's did have to go all the
way to Manchester New Hampshire
so they had you know they had to find a
place to set up shop the company didn't
have didn't own any manufacturing space
until the 1880s so this is 1873 so they
least some released a space on Market
Street and they had to advertise for
women to sew the pants and you know they
were very much in favor of it being
women of course and so here's a typical
ad this was in the San Francisco
Chronicle I believe in July of 1873
wanted 50 first class female sewing
machine operators who can bring their
own machines with them either singers
number two or growver in Baker's number
one for sewing heavy work
steady and remunerative employment at
4:15 Market Street upstairs all right I
read this and I thought oh my god I've
got this image of these poor women you
know dragging these machines of market
streets but they really were very small
and very portable at this time and it
was actually apparently not that unusual
for the women to take them around with
them but eventually the company did get
some sewing machines so that women
didn't have to bring their own so they
got lots of answers to the ads and the I
believe that by the 1880s there was I
was 32 and a half Fremont Street around
the corner from market was the company's
fully fledged absolutely owned owned and
operated Factory so Levi had brought
Jacob Davis from Reno to be in charge of
the manufacturing and Levi stayed with
the dry goods that's what he knew that
was his business so Jacob was in charge
Jacob and his family lived on Folsom
Street fairly near to the to the least
and the new factories and he became a
Levi Strauss and company employee groups
of which by the way do how to have a
good time this is an employee picnic on
Angel Island about 1899
so these pants were called overalls
because in the old days that's what
working pants were called if you wanted
like bib overalls you had to ask for
those specifically either engineer
overalls bib overalls but if you asked
for waist overalls or just overall you
got what we today call blue jeans and
they were this was work where this was
pure work where the denim the this 19th
century denim was really really tough
they wear like iron was an early
advertising slogan and it's very very
true so among the early consumers were
of course Cowboys and that's that stayed
as a classic consumer for a very very
long time
miners of course there was still a lot
of gold and silver being found all over
the west into the 1920s I mean even old
old pairs of Levi's were found in mind
that we know were finit in the 1920s we
know the pants a date to the 1920s
that's how long mining was going on and
agricultural workers this is I believe
elk deer elk Grove near Sacramento but
there was one person
one very important person who never wore
a pair of jeans in his life and that was
Levi Strauss it would be completely
inappropriate for him to wear jeans he
was not a laborer he was a wealthy
businessman he was a capitalist he wore
a black broadcloth suit away silk tie
and carried a top hat even this young
it's just I I guarantee you I'd stake my
reputation and my pension on the fact
that Levi Strauss never wore a pair of
jeans in his life so in 2006 the City of
Reno dedicated a plaque on Virginia
Street in Reno which is where Jacob
Davis had had his tailoring shop and in
June of 1870 or so in 1873 Levi bought
the building from Jacob so he could have
enough money to move to San Francisco
then in 1875 Levi's owned that property
he sold it back to Jacob Davis for $1
then Jacob Davis went around and sold it
again so Jacob made a tiny you know a
very tidy sum on that property which was
a lot the building was long gone but was
actually identified but the REIT by the
Reno historic Commission in 2006 and I
was very happy to have joined the join
the plaque ceremony that oldest pair of
jeans you saw earlier if they're it's
worth it's priceless but insurance value
worth about one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars is in that case that
I'm holding and I told them I would come
with the old jeans that they gave me
security so this is less my security
Wyatt and Morgan Earp fully armed yes
yeah they had a lot of fun driving me to
the reception afterwards they were
talking at each other like you know we
could just take those jeans and leave
her out in the desert you know oh it's a
fun day
so manufacturing is going on and the
company was making a lot of flyers and
we'll see a few in a couple minutes for
the sales people to give to potential
retail clients and a lot of them were
saying something called home industry
and this was 19th century code for the
fact that they only hired white women
and girls in the factory and this is one
of the pieces of Levi's history that is
classic and standard for San Francisco
history that I have the blessing
bob has on the entire house family to
talk about because that's how they told
me to write this book which is that
levi-strauss did not hire Chinese in his
factory because the discrimination in
San Francisco was about the Chinese the
railroad would have been completed in
1869 there were no more jobs white men
Chinese men were coming in to San
Francisco to look for jobs there was a
lot of hateful rhetoric and violence and
people didn't want their clothes made by
filthy Chinese who lived in that strange
place called Chinatown and ate strange
food but it was you know the rhetoric of
the time is truly horrendous and some of
it ended up on Levi Strauss and company
advertising this is a priceless that
would have gone to a retail store said
manufactured by white labor and there's
quite a few of those for a while it was
even stamped on the inside of the pocket
bag of the jeans it was a it was a
selling point it was a point of pride
for the company
I don't know how Levi Strauss personally
felt about the Chinese but as a
businessman he knew that there was no
way that he could sell his product and
keep his business unless he adhered to
the prevailing prejudice we don't like
it it's ugly if icky but it's real and
that is who he was that's one of the one
of the reasons that and I'll talk about
this later that I find him so fascinated
is because he's not predictable and he's
complicated and maybe at times he might
it might not have been very easy to like
but that's why that's why he was so
interesting to me so by the 1870s the
company was getting government contracts
for its dry goods they would bid with
the state to supply the dry goods for a
variety of state-funded organizations
and one of them was the Bureau of
Prisons and so for years 1870s into the
1880s Levi Strauss & Co had Co had the
dry goods contract for San Quentin
prison Folsom Prison and the Yuma
Territorial prison horrible place in
Arizona my personal favorite one though
this is the actual language language
from one of the contracts that says Levi
Strauss & Co won the bid to supply
striped flannel for convict suits at
Folsom Prison
yeah there you go now Levi Strauss & Co
products were sold to prisons but some
of Levi's customers should have been in
prison and I want to tell you a little
story
so one there was some very well-known
retailers in Arizona by the 1880s they
were michael and joseph goldwasser and
they moved to America via England and
Russia and they changed their name to
Goldwater and they had stores and all
kinds of businesses all over Arizona and
Joseph came to San Francisco quite a bit
to do the shopping for the stores at the
holse all the wholesale houses of San
Francisco on battery streets Anson
Street all over the place and Levi
Strauss & Co was a Goldwater's customer
but in 1881 the newspapers were just all
atwitter
because Joseph Goldwater left very
suddenly for the land of the rattlesnake
and tarantula a week ago Goldwater had
made extensive purchases on credit from
the biggest firms in San Francisco
including Levi Strauss & Co he then
hightailed it back to Arizona unable or
unwilling to pay for the goods so he
turned everything over to some partner
of his name Lyons in Yuma and then he
tells everybody I'm sorry I'm just not
paying so all lives all of the wholesale
merchants in San Francisco they called
the US Marshal the US Marshal and a few
other lawmen went to Yuma to either
retrieve the goods or arrest Goldwater
and his partner the Sacramento Daily
Record Union reported the defendants
have men barricaded on the premises
armed with shotguns who declared that
they would resist service at all hazards
the marshal for his part said that he
will serve the process regardless of
consequences if resistance is offered by
the mob there will surely be bloodshed
the posse are all determined men I mean
it's a John Wayne movie so what happens
the marshal shows up in Yuma they're
barricaded and what and they surrender
okay if we're sorry and so they arrest
Joseph Goldwater they bring it back to
San Francisco and they very quietly make
a little settlement for if you know a
few
you know pennies on the dollar for what
they owed and the incident just sort of
faded away
so the Goldwater's remained in you know
retail business in Arizona and Joseph
great-nephew eventually became a US
senator and in 1964 he ran for president
and what was his name
exactly so he had some very interesting
people to work with believe me and Levi
who knows what he I hope that he laughed
I mean I hope he had a good time with
that story but Levi had a side to him
and this is where we go back to how he's
expressing his face
oops Africa that was Goldwater so I
forgot showed gold letters there's gold
water in Coe I think it's in Phoenix so
about a year after Levi arrived in San
Francisco he made his first charitable
contributions it was $5 to the San
Francisco Orphan Asylum Society which
today by the way is the Edgewood Center
for children and families that still ads
out the Sunset District still in
business and he that was the beginning
of a life long process of philanthropy
that was personally important to him but
also very much a tenet of his Jewish
faith we know I it's really easy to
track his giving because a lot of it
showed up in the newspapers and I can
there there are personal donations that
he made and corporate donations and when
you see when I evaluated all where all
his money went you can see what meant
most to him personally a lot of his
money went to take care of young people
and to educate young people and in 1896
he became he began a rest of his life
association with the University of
California at Berkeley he and some other
men gave money to the University in 1896
to light the pathways on the campus and
to put lights in the library so the
students could stay later and study then
he heard in 1897 that the California
State Assembly had authorized
scholarships for every single asset
there were 35 Assembly districts in
California at that time and there was a
scholarship for one student from every
Assembly District which could be a huge
you know piece of geography and leave I
heard about this and he wrote to the
regent
Jacob Weinstein the head of the regions
of
University of california-berkeley and he
said I would like to match those
scholarships I would like to match that
money for every single Assembly District
in California and of course the Regents
accepted his offer and and created the
Levi Strauss scholarship which was first
awarded to 21 students half of which
were women in 1898 and that scholarship
is still in place today at UC Berkeley I
had the great honor of meeting the
latest crop of the Levi Strauss scholars
about a year but 2013 about a year
before I retired it's still on the books
still maintained by the family and it's
quite wonderful
so he's becoming this amazing
philanthropist and the but the business
is you know it keeps on going and he and
a lot of his other managers know that
when you have a patent on something so
they had an actual patent on the process
of making rivetted clothing you don't
get to keep that forever it's not like a
trademark eventually inventions have to
benefit the public domain so they knew
in 1892 that patent was going to run out
and anybody who wanted to could start
making rivetted clothing oh my god so
what the as we get closer and closer to
the 1890s the company started basically
branding the product in 1886 the famous
- horse pole we don't know if it was
revver real we don't know people have
tried first went on the pants was put on
the patch on the pants and also used in
print on Flyers on invoices everywhere
blanketed everything with this logo and
it was partly branding but I have a
feeling there was another reason for
this so not everybody in the American
West was literate and not everybody in
the American West spoke English as their
first language and if you go in a store
and there's some competitors you know
product there and you don't speak
English or you don't read you could say
well I want the one with the two horses
you know you can point to the picture of
the brand that you want with very very
smart marketing and I think probably
fairly common but that and the product
was called the two horse brand until
1927 when the company had to register
the name Levi's of the trademark because
Levi's was becoming a generic like
Kleenex but forever it
it's a two-horse brand so we don't have
a lot of images of as I call him uncle
Levi and a lot of them did survive the
fire they came from family members whose
belongings did not go up in flames one
of the other problems was doing research
on Levi as he died in his nephews house
on Lebanon where Street aguirre which
was also went down in the fire and so
anything personal in that family home of
his also was lost so that was you know
part of the problem corporate records as
well as personal records were gone but
this is one of the very very few so in
about 1890 the company started to assign
three-digit lot numbers to all of its
products and that's the way first see is
1890 or 1890 to this famous 501 and
here's what we have one of those you
know I need to drink my dinner at night
kind of days when people would tell me
oh I know where the number 501 came from
no you don't nobody knows I have series
all of the dry goods had four-digit lot
numbers and then the company had its own
manufactured products and everything got
a three-digit number everything had been
just sort of described the first pants
were just called xx double x overalls
but they were starting to make more
products and then competition was coming
in and I think it was there was this
desire that we're going to make it easy
for our retailers to order stuff we're
going to give everything a number
nobody knows where this number came from
my favorite reason my fitten no my
favorite literally published explanation
for this was some guy who put this in a
book the reason that the jeans were
first called 501 is because the first
jeans had 501 rivets on them
try walking in a pair of pants with a
501 rivets on them and don't go on the
Sun because those heat up as you know so
copper conducts heat so nobody knows and
there's also the mythology I don't have
a picture of there's a very famous
double arch of stitching on the back of
the pockets which the company calls the
arcuate which is the Greek word from the
Greek word meaning a bow like a bow and
arrow so when I first started with the
company I kept reading all of these
explanations oh it's the Wingspread of a
bird is this and this nobody knows
nobody knows but someone in the I think
in the company did say oh yes it
represents the wing spread of the Rocky
Mountain Eagle okay the Rocky Mountains
are not in California there's no such
bird as the Rocky Mountain eagle and
number three nobody knows so stop saying
it but it's still it's still out there
you know I'm fighting cyberspace you
know when I could just fight published
books and newspapers with all these
ridiculous stories it was okay now I'm
fighting cyberspace with all this stuff
out there but anyway that's one of the
reasons I read the book like stop saying
these things so the company started
making these beautiful handbills for
their salesmen to take two potential
retailers and again it's that visual
imagery visual branding you know give
you a picture to help you understand the
product kind of thing and this shows a
variety of the different products and
the different kind of men or children up
you know middle in the left that could
wear the products the flipside of this
has all the wonderful language about the
strength of the product the original you
know blah blah blah so but so any
retailer would have both of what he
needed visual visual branding and the
actual language there was newspaper
advertising and funky you know the Bodhi
courier and funky newspapers all over
the West really interesting visual you
know display ads as well with strong and
durable you know great language and then
my personal favorite
so this tells you everything you need to
know about how strong these pants are so
there's there's language you know
there's information there's the
two-horse and then there's the guy now
turn to the side whose face is that yeah
that's the Levi Strauss his face this
tells me the man had a sense of humor
and he didn't mind being caricatured for
his business and I just absolutely loved
this and not just because it reminds me
of the copper tone ad I just I just love
this because it's his face and this goes
along with with other stories that I
found in letters that people had had
written to the company all you know
earlier the century that his employees
called him Levi he wasn't mr. Strauss
even and his customers you know called
him Levi he did not have this you know
this barrier between himself and the men
who wore you know jeans or or people
that were you know his customers he
really appeared to be a truly personable
and apparently a guy with a great sense
of humor one thing that we think is kind
of modern you know you go to a store and
you buy something of a certain price you
get a gift with purchase that goes back
a really long way this is a gift with
purchase the flip side of this is that
eighteen ninety-nine calendar and these
were created for all of the company's
retailers
if you bought two Levi product you would
be given this lovely little calendar as
a gift and printed for free on the
calendar was the name of your friendly
retailer so you would remember where you
got it they also created something
called trade cards every consumer
product company in America made trade
cards they were they were like business
cards but people collected them like
baseball cards and they would paste them
into scrapbooks so the company created
ones with miners on them there were ones
for the engineers overalls again there
was a little bit of language on the back
the name of the retailer printed for
free
you bought a Levi's product you got a
trade card was a very very valuable and
effective way to spread your word so by
the 1880s 1890s you know here's a
you know the battery street they're
taking over the entire building I know
the block is really beautiful there were
you know pictures that the signs the
levi-strauss sign was so huge you know
you saw pictures there forever and then
this is actually from the 1900
blue-and-gold
the UC Berkeley yearbook from 1900 it
was called our benefactors and there's
Levi on the Left right next to Phoebe
Apperson Hearst which is kind of kind of
interesting the first recipients of the
Levi Strauss scholarship surprised Levi
at his home one night and he just
happened to be visited by Jacob
Weinstein and Phoebe Apperson hearse at
night and the students all trooped in
all 21 of them and presented him with a
plaque thanking him for the scholarship
that he had created that enabled all of
them to go to college which of course
was lost in the flames so here he is
near the end of his life again the happy
you know philanthropist a happy
capitalist Levi never married he moved
in with his sister Fanny and her family
when he was in his early 40s and then
she passed away and then he he lived
with his oldest nephew who was Jacob
Stern it was Jacob Stern's house where
he was living when he passed away and
that was the house that went down in
1906 this is in Atherton he was probably
visiting some family friends one of his
nephews is there on the far right I like
this picture it's you know probably
taken after lunch you know and they're
all really tired let's go have a picture
out by the tree again one of those few
that we have in 1900 Levi Strauss had
left Boonton Heim almost 50 years
earlier in 1900 he heard that the
cemetery in his home village in Boonton
Heim was falling apart and the town
fathers wanted to refurbish it they
wanted to straighten the headstones
clean them do all the weeding but they
didn't have enough money he said half
the amount of money needed to completely
renovate the cemetery in his home
village and they were able to do it and
he had he had not lived there for almost
50 years he'd never been back as far as
we know but he'd somehow kept in touch
with people in Boonton Heim and heard
about this need this is his father's
grave which I had the privilege
visit back in 2009 so his father was
buried there
his grandparents were there his family
was still there nobody else as you saw
as you heard and you know in his
statement none of his family remained in
Boonton Heim but it was important that
his family sent his family's graves be
taken care of I'm sure that was the most
poignant and important personal
contribution of his entire life he died
on September 26 1900 he was 73 years old
he had not even really been ill he maybe
hadn't felt so good for a couple of days
and went to bed after dinner and went to
sleep and never woke up the funeral was
held out of his home Jacob for Sanger
the rabbi of Temple emanu-el gave the
eulogy they had a special train to go
down to Home of Peace in Colma they
closed the business for the day so all
the employees could come to the funeral
and the all of all of the language from
the eulogy you know people always say
nice things about people at your funeral
right but I have a feeling that every
wonderful thing that was said about
Levite was true and everything seemed so
very very sincere and then there were so
many obituaries and articles about him
in newspapers after his death that just
seemed to echo everything that the rabbi
had said that makes me really feel that
it was very very true so the earthquake
and fire happens the building goes down
and he had left the business to his four
nephews he had four nephews and three
nieces in his will he left the business
which is the majority of his business to
the nephews he left lots of money to
orphanages mostly orphanages and what
were called the benevolent associations
these were organizations mostly
for the Jewish indigent widows and
orphans people who weren't able to take
care of themselves there was the Eureka
benefit benevolent society the first
Hebrew benevolent society he left a lot
of money to them and then he left each
of his nieces 25,000 dollars not to
their husbands to administer for them
but directly to his nieces and then the
bulk of the business to his four nephews
now they were incredible in his estate
by the way was valued at six million
dollars and that's 6 million 1902
dollars so the four nephews didn't have
to work they were
incredibly wealthy they had real estate
that could have just skated on their
money the rest of their lives but they
didn't do that they rebuilt the company
they rebuilt the building on the very
same place I mean where else you're
going to go in San Francisco it was 98
battery this building is still there
it's at the corner of pine and the
company was there from 1908 until the
1970s when they went to Embarcadero
Center
so the staring brothers also kept the
company name they could have started
over they could have said oh now we're
stirring brothers no it was Levi Strauss
& Co again so the the family - the
family that owns the companies day is
the Haas family I'm sure that almost
everybody in this room has heard them
and even knows how they're related but
I'll give you the family tree so Levi
son of Levi stresses nephews was Sigmund
Stern you put all heard of Sigmund Stern
Grove
well that was Levi's nephew Sigmund and
he and his wife had a daughter named
Elise and a Li's Stern married mr.
Walter Hawes senior the gentleman in
this photo and it's his descendants that
owned the company today
his grandson Bob Hodge the adorable
child on the right is the man who hired
me for my job as historian and he is the
reason I called Levi uncle Levi because
he is a great great grand nephew of Levi
Strauss himself and it is a hospital II
that of course still owns the company
now Jacob Davis sold his interest in the
patent back to the company about 1906
and then he died in 1908 his son Simon
worked for Levi's for about 20 years and
then he left and started his own
clothing business which didn't really do
very well then in 1935 he opened another
business which he named after his son
and that is still in business today
which is Ben Davis the work clothing
company the little with the little
gorilla on the label Ben Davis with
Jacob Davis's grandson and they're still
in business today so Levi Plaza was
built in are opened in 1982
it's where the archives is and of course
still a mainstay of San Francisco it's
right on battery street
there's if you've ever been there
there's a beautiful fountain designed by
Lawrence Halprin and there's a remains
of a gold rush ship underneath when they
were excavating for Levi's Plaza the
maritime museum did a study because they
came across these remains of his old
ship and were able to do an amazing
study of what was there so that's where
the companies of course still operates
today now in Boonton Heim about 1998 the
city finally was able to figure out
which house Levi Strauss had been born
in and it was still there this is
actually a nineteenth-century photograph
city bought the house and turned it into
a museum and it is a Levi Strauss museum
same wonderful place
Booton home is about this big it's a
wonderful village it's like full of
breweries and fascinating people and
they hired a tremendous young woman to
be the director of this museum her name
is Tanya rappelled and she's the reason
I was able to go to the State Archives
in Bamberg and she was the one who found
so much of the German documentation
about Levi's life translated it for me
is the reason we have that story from
his early years it's a lovely lovely
place I insist that you go you find a
nürnberg you get a car and you go and
it's really really and call Tanya first
and she'll give you a great tour it's
truly a lovely place so so many
biographers when they spend their lives
or years and years you know with a with
a subject sometimes to get to the end of
their book and they're like oh I'm sick
of this person one of my book going to
be done you know and that never happened
to me it never happened to me at all
working on this book and the reason is
because of something I said earlier Levi
was so complicated he wasn't that
cardboard cutout he was truly a loving
uncle a tremendous philanthropist and he
was a hard-ass if you didn't pay your
bills even if you were a friend you need
to pay your bill or you give me back
this stuff we're done I mean he was that
he was so contradictory which is what I
mean you know he wasn't boring I'm sure
he wasn't boring to be around but that's
why he was so fascinating to me as a
subject for a book and why I just
continually was fascinated everything I
found out about him it just added to
this amazing story
early in my career I met a gentleman dr.
John Michael who lives in Marin County
he is the great great grandson of Jonas
Strauss Levi's oldest brother and their
family does have a photo that they were
able they were not living in San
Francisco at the during the earthquake
and fire or they were able to save it
and he had always lets me use this
picture at the end of my at the end of
my talk I absolutely adore this picture
it's the only one where we really see
him smiling and he is he's got his cigar
he's got his Panama hat and I just love
this picture and I hope that he was as
happy as he looks near the end of his
life in 1960 some very smart person at
Levi Strauss & Co went around and
interviewed people they track down
people who had worked for the company
when Levi was still alive they talked to
a sewing machine operator who had worked
for the company in the 1890s and they
said what was Levi like and she said he
was tough but a fine fellow
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much and of course I'm
happy to answer questions and you have
to stand at the micro won't end up on
the foot from what I'm told
don't be shy you can just raise your
hand and walk over or just line up
whatever you want to do hi there I grew
up in Fisherville Pennsylvania my
parents have built a home from the
previous that there was a mill mill our
home and our home had been the
superintendent of the mills home so I
knew this mill very well because we
start like our playground it was not
operating now it had been to all reports
a manufacturer of Kentucky genes for
Civil War veterans in other words how to
Kentucky gene to predate levi-strauss
come into this picture I'm glad you
asked that question because the word
gene and genes is one of those textile
conservator archived arm wrestling
matches things there was a fabric called
jeans JEA n which was being made at the
same time as denim and it tended to be
indigo blue just like denim was it was a
it was easily absorbed by the cotton you
know was a color that everybody liked
you know whatever pants made of Jean
fabric were called jeans and actually
kentucky jeans was a very specific type
of pant and it originally was made in
kentucky but again it was one of those
things everybody knew what kentucky
jeans were and they were made in other
places but not necessarily always in
kentucky but there was made of jeans
fabrics denim is one colored thread and
one white thread together Jean fabric
was two threads of the same color so it
looks like denim but it didn't have you
know denim will have that white that
kind of will kind of note the fill will
come through a little bit Jean fabric
was just you know blue so jeans
levi-strauss old jeans pants and his dry
goods inventory before the jeans were
invented here's why we call them jeans
today so men had worn undone riveted
denim pants for a long time and they
were just called you know denim overalls
when Levi Strauss and Jacob Davis what
Ribbit's and those for the first time it
created a new category of work where
which is the Blue Gene but they were
called overalls until about the 1950s
and then teenage boys who saw Marlon
Brando wear 501 jeans and movies with
you know scary motorcycle guy they
wanted to be like him and they wanted to
wear those pants but their dads called
them overalls so they started calling
them jeans they didn't want to wear
overalls like their dads it had to be
jeans cool jeans pants like Marlon
Brando did I don't even really know why
they appropriated that word but it was
the new word you know it was just a new
word for the pants that were already
there and it was a new modern word for
something that had been around since the
1870s so Kentucky genes were pants made
out of gene fabric I know it's very
confusing I try to cover in the book but
I don't know how successful I was who
else oh come on step up oh come up to
the microphone I am very curious to know
why he never married did you find any
evidence of a relationship ever in
Germany here was he just married to his
job what's the story well he gave a
number of interviews in which he said
his life was his business but we have no
letters we have no Diaries we have
nothing everybody always asked me that
question we don't know if he was gay we
don't know there's no way to know unless
the one thing about history is that you
never know somebody might the next phone
call might be somebody who said oh my
god I found a diary oh my god I found
some letters but again because so much
of his personal stuff was gone we just
don't know the fact that he moved in
with his sister when he was in his early
40s tells me that he just probably never
even had any intention to and if you
think about it he was sent out here in
his 20s to be the West Coast branch of
the business he had to build a business
to help support his family back in New
York he might have had this just had so
much on his shoulders that he decided
that his you know his life was his
business and that's that's the only
quote I ever found it even comes close
to explaining it but unless we find new
records we'll never know
go on I was wondering about the history
of the factory on Valencia Street
oh yes the the Valencia Street factory
was built in 1906 after the Fremont
Street factory went down in the
earthquake and fire so we've put up very
quickly it opened in November of 1906
and it was a working Factory we still at
working factory when I started in 1989
and then little by little a lot of the
building which is huge was turned over
to laboratory and laundries and a lot of
experimentation and they were still
making 501 jeans for the Japanese market
into the early 1890s but it just became
you know too expensive to manufacture
out of the out of the the property so in
2008 I believe the company sold the
building to the San Francisco Friends
School and they give the money to the
Mission redevelopment fund I believe so
the money went back into the Mission
District and what I love is that the the
San Francisco Friends school they
completely renovated the building but
they kept the soul of the building there
they reused a lot of the materials on
the inside for for staircases a lot of
the lot of their benches so they recycle
a lot of the interior of the building it
had lots of long hallways it was perfect
for it for a class it still retains you
know the wonderful soul of the factory
how did you find the oldest pair of
jeans how did I find the oldest pair of
jeans somebody called me on the phone in
25 years I was able one of my Jobs was
to shop and spend the company's money on
really old jeans and I rarely had to go
anywhere to do it because once people
knew that the company was buying vintage
products that people just you know
showed up and it was a private dealer
and who always wanted to remain
anonymous and he sold it to the company
for a lot less than its value I mean
they are valued at over one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars but it was it was
somebody who found them people rarely
told me where they found the old jeans
because they didn't want anybody going
where they found them in case there were
more so as a historian it always made me
crazy there was no provenance
you know I think we knew maybe the the
provenance or previous owner of maybe
two or three of the other really really
old pieces of denim in the archives but
they just sort of would mysteriously
come out of barns and cellars and mines
and trunks and sometimes we just didn't
know two questions actually I'm curious
about the timeline when some of the
changes were made like the rivet at the
bottom to fly the rivet on the back
pockets and the second question would be
the pairs that they found the trunk
recently what those end up selling for I
don't know the answer the second
question because I know work at the
company anymore and I don't know I
haven't heard anything about that the
changes the jeans went over time and
usually we're because of changes in
fashion and wanting to modernize you
know what the jeans were so the part of
the rivets on the back pockets were
always on the outside but then in the
1920s and 30s the company was getting
complaints saying your rivets are
scratching our saddles and our our
school decks and our car hoods which I
don't know about that and so what the
company did was put the rivets in the
pockets but then so the pockets over so
the rivets were there but then they you
know they wouldn't scratch but they were
eventually taken out completely and I
think 1967 there was a rivet at the base
of the button fly the indelicately named
Korat rivet and there was all this
anecdotal evidence you know people were
writing in you know when we crouched in
front of a campfire
this rivet heats up in a really delicate
place and the companies like what a
bunch of wimpy Cowboys and then it
happened to the president of the company
mr. Walter Hawes but about that time it
was world war two had started and
American clothing manufacturers had to
take a certain amount of metal off of
their clothing and so I'm sure there was
a meeting at the companies like okay
nobody likes this rivet we have to get
rid of some rivets it's going and it
never came back until the company
started to make replicas of its historic
jeans again so just if you have a pair
don't crouch in front of a campfire I'm
telling you so so those kind of changes
again we're changes in fashion wartime
you know whatever and I'm always because
of necessity no more questions
well thank you again so much for coming
out I really appreciate it
[Applause]
I guess we're going to sign some books
505 desk did you like membership if you
would like to buy membership is 20% off
tonight
as well thank you for coming